The following content
is provided by MIT
OpenCourseWare, under a Creative
Commons license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu
PROFESSOR: The final quiz is
scheduled for a week from
today, on December 8.
Following that weekend, we'll
have one class on the 13th.
And the last days of classes
are Monday, Tuesday, and
Wednesday, the 12th,
13th, and 14th.
So I know a number of you spoke
up last time and said
that you have a conflict on
Thursday, the eighth, with a
quiz in another class.
So could I see a show of hands
again of how many of you have
this conflict?
So three, six people, seven
people, you're going to enroll
in the other course just
so you can put
off taking the quiz.
That's unfortunate, I don't
think anybody should have to
take two quizzes in one day.
We can't move it up.
We'll have to move it back.
So I don't know if I am
violating any Institute rule,
but I know that it is strictly
illegal to give assignments
that are due after the last day
of classes, let alone have
a quiz after the last day of
classes, which has not been
previously scheduled as
a final examination.
So we can't give it after
Wednesday, the 14th, the last
day of classes.
So, do any of the six impacted
people have a strong
preference for when we should
schedule the quiz?
AUDIENCE: Monday?
PROFESSOR: Due it Monday?
It doesn't have to
be that soon.
Monday?
AUDIENCE: Why not Tuesday?
PROFESSOR: Because Tuesday
we have a class.
AUDIENCE: Or Wednesday?
Well we would have a Thursday
class instead.
Correct?
PROFESSOR: No.
If we're doing it after
the quiz next
week, there's a class.
We have a last meeting
here on the 13th.
And I'm not going to shift
it for other people,
just for the impacted.
So of the six who are entitled
to vote, how many would prefer
to have it Monday, the 12th?
Three and I know how it's
going to turn out.
And for Wednesday, the 14th?
Three.
AUDIENCE: I can't take the test
because-- not because of
another test--
I'm out of town.
And I might come
back Saturday.
And Monday is just a little
quick to take it
after we get back.
PROFESSOR: I think I'm going to
have to make an executive--
yes
AUDIENCE: Professor, when you
mean by conflict, do you mean
having an exam at
the exact time?
PROFESSOR: No, it's on
the exact same day.
Considering this is a two hour
examination, to have another
examination exactly the same
day, if you're not brain dead
after an hour or two, you will
be pretty close to it.
So I think that is an unfair
penalty to pay.
I think, to keep it as close as
possible to the quiz that
the rest of the people will be
taking, why don't we make it--
since it's a tie vote--
on Monday, the 12th.
Do it sooner, rather
than later.
And I'll let you know next time
of where we will hold it.
I'll have to arrange
a room for it.
So that will not be
a make-up quiz.
It would be a made-up--
invented--
quiz.
And, as I say on Monday, I
should have all of the
homework and the previous
quiz to return to you.
Reason you don't have it now
is all the little crabbed
handwriting that you see before
you in the form of
these notes, which
takes forever.
All right, so since we've
satisfied the unpleasant
aspects of the end of the
term, let's get back to
discussing some of the other
piezoelectric effects that we
have defined.
And then also ask the question
rhetorically, is there
anything like a representation
surface for a third-ranked
tensor property?
And it doesn't look promising.
But there are some things that
we can do to discuss variation
of properties with direction,
and we'll see
directly what those are.
But first let's look at the
converse piezoelectric effect.
And this again is a third-ranked
tensor property,
but what we do is to have the
elements of strain, epsilon
ij, a second-ranked tensor.
And to take advantage of this
curious relation between the
directed converse effects,
we define the converse
piezoelectric effect as giving
you nine elements of strain in
terms of a third-ranked tensor
dijk times e sub i.
So what is not standard is our
convention for the order of
the subscripts on the moduli.
And we make up the rules, we
can do it any way we like.
And the advantage of defining
it this way, in nonstandard
tensor notation, is that we can
use the same coefficients
for both the direct and
the converse effects.
So let me-- to illustrate what
these equations look like--
write out a few examples.
Epsilon 11 would be d1jk
times e sub 1.
I'm writing it in simple
fashion, and not expanding
fully, just to save
space and time.
Epsilon 22 would be
d2jk times e2.
Epsilon 33 will be d3jk
times epsilon 3.
And let me stop after these six
terms, and write, at least
for these, an expansion.
Because this gives us some
interesting information.
I'm not doing the equal
signs in here.
So this would say that the
element of strain epsilon 11
is d111 times e1 plus d112 times
e2 plus d113 times e3.
And I want to say this is 11k.
And I want to say that
this is 22k.
The next term would be epsilon
22, and that would be d122
times epsilon 2 plus d212.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't the
2's be balanced?
PROFESSOR: Hm?
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't
that be d2's?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you're right.
This should be epsilon jk equals
dijk times e sub i.
So this is all e1.
This is e1.
And this one goes
with this one.
This 2 goes with this one.
You're right.
d2 and this is the
d311 times e11.
This would be 122 times
e1 plus 222 times e2
plus d322 times e3.
And the fourth one would be e33
equals d133 times e1 plus
d233 times e2 plus
d333 times e3.
OK, these elements here are the
three that appear in the
box that I had indicated
for the terms djk.
When we write the direct
piezoelectric effect, this
would be the box of
coefficients.
When we write the converse
effect, this is the box of
coefficients.
And now what I wanted to point
out is that delta v over v is
equal to episilon 11 plus
epsilon 22 plus epsilon 33,
which is the trace of
the strain tensor.
And we're going to get one set
of terms which depends on the
x1 component of the field,
another set of three terms
that depend on the x2 component
of the field, and
another one on the
x3 component.
If these expressions sum
to 0, then there would
be no volume change.
So this first set of 3--
3 of the first 6 equations--
give you an indication of when
the application of a field
will result in no volume
change in the sample.
And that again, I remind you,
can be for two reasons.
It could be because all of
these six of the nine
piezoelectric moduli are 0.
Or alternatively, if you
examined the form of the
piezoelectric moduli matrices
that is required by symmetry
constraints, you'll find that
there are a substantial number
of point groups for which
some terms are 0.
But then there is, in addition,
an equality between
some of the other terms, which
make the volume change zero.
Even though, not all of the
elements within this 1/2 box
of moduli are zero.
So that is an interesting
effect.
And it turns out that
the majority of the
non-centrosymmetric point groups
do not have a volume
change, when you apply in a
field in any way you choose.
A few do, but it's a minority.
Alright, but this is not the
main point of writing this.
I want to--
at this point--
point out that this tells you
about the volume change.
And then we would have
additional terms, we would
have a term of the form e1
something like e123 or e132.
And this would be e14.
This would also be e14 since
we replace both of those
subscripts by a single
subscript.
And the tensor elements
that would go in
here would be d123.
We just want one of the them.
d123 times e1, and then we want
d223 times e2, and then
d323 times e3.
We're writing one of the
specific equations for the
shear strings.
If we write the expression for
d132, this is going to be d132
times e1 plus d232 times
e2 plus d332 times e3.
There are two interesting
consequences of this.
The strain tensor
is symmetric.
And this element of strain--
why have I got three
subscripts in here?
Don't want that one in there.
These two strains are equal.
And therefore, if we would apply
just an e1 for example,
let e be equal to just a
component of field along x1.
The strains have to be equal.
But we have two different
tensor elements here.
And the only way that strain
can be symmetric, and it's
defined as such, is that d123
be identical to d132.
And that resolves the issue
that came up in connection
with the direct case
electric effect.
We said the direct piezoelectric
effect depends
just on the sum of the elements
dijk and dikj.
And since they're lumped
together, all we can measure
is the sum.
And, so, we'll just have
to call that a
single matrix element.
The converse piezoelectric
effect tells us these tensor
elements have to be equal,
if the strain
tensor is to be symmetric.
So that says that, since we
defined d16 as the sum of d123
plus d132, this says that d132
is equal to d123 is equal to
1/2 of d16, just making
the equality
in the reverse direction.
The converse effect let's us
say that 123 has to be 132,
that any ijk has to be
equal to a dijk.
So if I tried now to write this
first expression in the
reduced subscript notation,
e23 is what we let e5 be.
And now we have this equal to
and in our reduced subscripts,
we have this as 1/2 of d16.
And the field that's
multiplying this is
piezoelectric modulus is e1.
And that messy factor of 2 has
come back to haunt us again.
It's like trying to stuff
a jack-in-the
box back in the box.
It keeps popping up.
We ate the factor of 2 in
defining the matrix
representation of the
piezoelectric electric modulus.
And now when we try to go to a
reduced subscript notation for
the converse piezoelectric
effect, we've
got a 1/2 in there.
And similarly, the second
equation would be e5--
same result epsilon 5--
and it's 132, but 132 is
1/2 of d16 times e1.
And we have a similar mess for
the other coefficients here.
So what do we do?
Do we say that the relation
between strain epsilon j
equals dij e sub j has 1/2 in
front of several of the
coefficients and
not in others?
Well, we can't really absorb
the factor of 2 in the
definition of the piezoelectric
moduli, because
we've already done that.
So the only thing we can do is
to say that we will have to
take the off diagonal strains,
and define them as having a
1/2 in front, and
we add these up.
So we will have to write matrix
strain in this reduced
subscript notation.
We'll have to take e11, epsilon
12, epsilon 13,
epsilon 21, epsilon 22, epsilon
23, epsilon 31,
epsilon 32, and epsilon 33.
And in converting this to matrix
form, we'll call this
epsilon 1, analogous
to what we did
for the tensile stresses.
We'll call this epsilon
2 and this epsilon 3.
And then for all of the
off-diagonal elements of
strain, in order to avoid the
factor of 2 popping up in
front of the matrix
representation of the
piezoelectric moduli, we're
going to have to put in here
1/2 of epsilon 4, 1/2 of epsilon
5, and 1/2 of epsilon
6, and same for the off diagonal
terms 1/2 of epsilon
5, 1/2 of epsilon 4, and
1/2 of epsilon 6.
So the moral of this story is
that you can't win, but if you
play it right, you can
come out even.
So only if we define the reduced
subscript strains in
this fashion, can we write an
expression of this form.
So this algebra is carried
through for you for the other
elements in the notes.
But this is the way we are
forced, unless we want to have
a factor of 2 in some terms, and
not in others, is the way
we have to define
matrix strain.
All this is formalism and
definition, but I'd like to
now do two things.
First of all, give you some
examples of real numbers for
piezoelectric moduli, and then
ask the question about
representation surfaces.
Once again, these numbers are in
the handout for you, so you
don't have to make
note of them.
But one of the very important
piezoelectric materials is the
quartz form of SiO2.
SiO2 has many polymorphic
forms.
Quartz is the form that's stable
at room temperature,
and it has point group
32 asymmetric.
And there are higher
temperature
polymorphs of SiO2.
There's a phase transition in
quartz to a more symmetric
form, and then there are cubic
forms at the highest
temperatures.
Now, quartz is not the material
that displays the
largest piezoelectric moduli.
But it has the following
advantages.
One is it is a naturally
occurring material that is
very inexpensive.
So it's not an exotic
expensive material.
Very stable.
It's not water soluble.
Extremely tough.
You can take a thin wafer of
quartz, for example, if you
want to make a monochromator for
a diffraction experiment.
You can take a thin wafer of
quartz, and bend it like this,
and it does not break,
very elastic.
And if you want a material
that's going to earn its
living by being squished, you
want something that doesn't
plastically deform and something
that is very hard
and resistant to stress.
So quartz, even though the
moduli are not the largest, is
a very attractive material,
and is used in
a variety of devices.
There was a time when CB radios
were very, very popular.
Everybody had to have
one in their car.
I guess so they could pretend
that they were truck drivers.
But anyway, you don't have
them anymore now that
cellphones have come
in in existence.
But for your CB radio,
you needed
something called a crystal.
And they were fairly
expensive.
And the number of channels on
which you could communicate
dependent on the number of
crystals that you could plug
into your CB radio.
The so-called crystal
was exactly that.
It was a little black box that
looked almost like a
transistor.
And there were two leads
coming out of it.
If you ever got curious and
broke this thing open, what
you found was a nice
wafer of quartz.
And on the wafer of quartz--
brazed onto it--
were two wires.
And that's all there
was in the box.
The crystal really
was a crystal.
And the crystals had been
very precisely ground to
thicknesses such that when a
field caused these wafers to
hit a resonance, that resonance
would be at exactly
a particular frequency.
And that was the frequency
of that channel.
One of the crises, during the
Second World War, is that the
highest quality natural crystals
of quartz come from
Brazil, and during the conflict
the sea channels were
essentially blocked.
And so, people-- in order
to make all these
communication devices--
had to learn how to synthesize
crystals of quartz
synthetically.
And there are a number of
companies, such as Sylvania up
on the North Shore, that
developed entire buildings
devoted to growing single
crystals of quartz.
And they're big tanks like
something out of the aquarium.
And in the center of the tank is
a rod, and seeds of quartz
are placed on the rod.
And the thing very
slowly rotates
around in this solution.
And on the rod, eventually, are
single crystals of quartz
that are this size.
And its a very spectacular
thing to see.
In any case, symmetry
3 2, and the moduli
that are 0 and non-zero.
If we refer the reference axes
to a set of coordinates with
x1 in this direction, and x2--
since it has to be orthogonal
to x1-- in between the
two-fold axes, and x3.
And for all materials of
commerce that are anisotropic,
there has to be some standard
for defining
the choice of axes.
For example, crystallographers
would say the unique axis
should be along the z direction,
the x3 direction.
But why isn't x1 and x2 in
between the two-fold axis?
There's some professional
society that is responsible
for giving standards for
representing property
measurements in some mutually
agreed upon form.
And this is the standard set
of axes for the quartz and
symmetry 3, 2.
The moduli, dij, not dijk, but
dij, these two are constrained
to be equal.
This one is 0.
This is minus 0.67, 0, 0, 0, 0,
0, 0, 0.67, 4.6, 0, 0, 0,
0, 0, 0, 0.
One of the strange materials
for which no field
can create a strain--
field along x3 cannot
create a strain.
And these are all in units of
10 to the minus 12 coulombs
per Newton.
An example they give you here,
if you apply a field of 100
volts per centimeter, which is
not terribly large, but would
be comparable to what
you have in some
electronic device, perhaps.
So this, since our units are
MKS, this would correspond to
10 to the 4 volts per meter.
The strain epsilon 1, which
is d11 times e1.
It turns out to be minus 2.3,
which means it contracts.
That's the significance of the
negative times 10 to the 4.
And that turns out to be
10 to the minus 12
times 10 to the fourth.
That turns out to be a strain
of minus 2.3 times 10 to the
minus eighth.
10 to the minus eighth is not
exactly a large point strain.
You're not going to see the
crystal wafer twitch and jump,
if you apply a field
of 100 volts on it.
But yet, even a strain of
this sort is more than
enough to be useful.
But this is just to illustrate
that quartz is not the most
sensitive of piezoelectric
materials.
Another one that I give you
data for is so-called ADP.
And this is a widely
used material.
This is ammonium dihydrogen
phosphate.
And this is one of the family of
salts that have very large
piezoelectric responses.
The nice part about it is that
it's water soluble, so you can
grow very, very large crystals
easily from solution.
The nasty part about it is that
it is water soluble, so
you have to be careful to
protect this material from
moisture if you're going to use
it in any sort of device.
But if we look at the moduli,
relative to the standard axes,
and this has point
group 4-bar 2m.
So x3 is taken along
the 4-bar access.
Then there are two-fold axes
and orientations like this.
And since they are orthogonal,
you can take both x1 and x2
along the two-fold axes.
And the numbers here for dij,
are 0, 0, 0, 1.7, 0, 0, 0, 0,
0, 0, 1.7, 0.
This is one of the interesting
tensors where there's a
diagonal row of non-zero terms
off on the right hand side.
And finally, the big surprise
is the third
modulus this is 51.7.
So you can see this has
a very strong effect.
This is over 10 times
the maximum
piezoelectric modulus in quartz.
So this is a material that's
very commonly used in
transducers.
This is again times ten to the
minus 12 coulombs per Newton.
One of the very, very exciting
developments in recent years
is a class of materials
that are perovskites.
And they are very, very new.
I gave you the reference to
the first one that was
reported, and that was just
in the spring of 2000.
And these are perovskites.
Perovskites are materials that
in the type form are cubic.
But depending on composition
and temperature, they can
transform to a distorted version
of this very simple
cubic structure that
is tetragonal.
And this material can exhibit
piezoelectric effects.
And whether it distorts or not
depends on the relative sizes
of what goes into
the perovskite.
Perovskite has a composition
ABO3 like barium titanate is
one example.
And the material has two
different cations.
And they have different
valences so they have
different sizes.
And I won't bother to describe
the structure, but it is only
a very restricted locus in the
field RA versus RB, where both
the A and the B can remain in
contact with the oxygen
without distortion.
And it turns out to be a line
that does something like that.
Any other perovskite-- and there
are lots of them in this
field of radii--
has to have one of the ion
sort of flopping around.
And if that gets too serious,
the structure distorts so that
all these ions can remain in
contact with the oxygen.
OK in order to do that,
many of them distort
to tetragonal forms.
Others distort to super
structures, which have very,
very large unit cells.
But in any case, when you're
right at the phase boundary
between the distorted structure
and the true
perovskite structure, these
materials sometimes have very,
very complicated x solutions of
the two phases, on a very
sort of fine scale.
And it's not known exactly why
they have this property.
But they have absolutely
enormous piezoelectric moduli,
very close to this
phase boundary.
And the references that I give
you-- here-- is a compound
that is a lead titanium
zinc niobate.
And the complicated composition
is to get you
close to this phase boundary.
This has a d333 that is greater
than 2,000 picocuries
per Newton.
And pico is 10 to
the minus 12.
So this is a piezoelectric
electric modulus that is 10 to
the 3 times d11 for quartz.
So 3 orders of magnitude
stronger than this very
commonly used piezoelectric
material.
Some of these materials have
strains getting close to 1%.
So this is something that will
actually twitch on the lab
bench, when you apply
a field to it.
So these are entirely new.
People still don't know the
origin of this behavior.
And it's still under
considerable study.
So this is a new family
of materials.
It's very exciting, and
undergoing a lot of
investigation and development
work at the moment.
Alright, we are almost
out of time.
Time goes fast when
you're having fun.
Let me raise the question that
we'll consider next time,
which will be one of
our last lectures.
And that is, is it possible to
create representation surfaces
that tell you how the
piezoelectric properties of a
particular material will
vary with direction?
Well, vary with what?
Well, we talk about the direct
piezoelectric effect.
This gives us components of--
well let's look at the
simpler one, in
terms of what we apply.
We have the converse
piezoelectric effect that says
that epsilon ijk is going to
be dijk times e sub i.
So we've got a piece of
material, and we apply a
field, e sub i.
So we can vary this in space
relative to a coordinate
system x1, x2, x3.
But how in the world are we
going to show what happens?
So I always do an extra
thing in here.
There are 9 components
to the strain
tensor, which is symmetric.
So they're really six responses
that are unique.
So yes, we can define
the direction
of the applied field.
But they're going to be
6 different strains.
So we're going to need six
representation surfaces.
One for each of the three
tensile strains, and one for
each of the three
shear strains.
So you can't do it with
a single surface.
So you can't do much other than
say, there are certain
responses which are intended
to emphasize one particular
sort of strain or one
particular sort of
polarization.
So one of the things we might do
is to cut a very thin plate
of something like quartz,
and subject it
to a uniaxial stress.
So let's say sigma along
the x3 axis.
So we're looking at a very
restricted strain tensor.
That's 0, 0, 0, 0, 0,
0, 0, 0, sigma 3.
And in response to that strain,
there are going to be
three different components
of the polarization.
Polarization is manifested as
a charge per unit area.
So if we make a very
thin plate--
to be sure there will
be charges induced
on these thin edges--
but if it's got a surface area
that's a large compared to the
area of these thin edges, we
are going to be measuring
primarily p3--
the component of polarization
that's
normal to this surface--
and that might have a charge
per unit area that is
comparable to these other
two charged surfaces.
But because the area by design
of our specimen is so large,
the response that would be most
easy to detect, and which
would be the largest response,
by design, would be p3, which
is the charge per unit
area on this surface.
So this is an effect we can
define for a particular
sample, and for a particular
special form of the
generalized force.
And we then can ask, what is
the value of the single
modulus that relates
p3 to sigma 3?
And that's a question
we can ask.
And we can plot that response as
a function of direction of
a plate that we consider as
being cut out of a single
crystal, and different
orientations, and then ask how
this modulus--
which connects the two--
changes with the orientation
of x3.
So that is a question
we can ask.
And these surfaces are
absolutely wild, highly
anisotropic, can be identically
zero in certain
special directions, and they
are very interesting, and a
lot of fun to look at.
So we'll take a quick look at a
couple of those, which won't
come as a surprise because
they're already worked out for
you in the notes.
So we'll take a look
at one of those.
And in the problem set, I invite
you to amuse yourself
by looking at such
representation surfaces for
two other point groups.
And with that, having kept
you til five after
the hour I will quit.